good morning John how's it going just
setting up my shot here this video out
of script which I usually don't do so
we're just going to go right off the
cuff here to see what happens
finally got to see Paper Towns I'm feel
bad that it took me so long to do it is
a weird thing with your movie career if
you can call it that we started off with
The Fault in Our Stars and boy was that
something right like it kid number one
movie in America beating out a Tom
Cruise movie that was really quite good
I saw it later even if I have a hard
time figuring out what the title was
because they didn't seem to be sure
themselves what the title was whether it
was edge of tomorrow or live die repeat
and I later found out that that movie
was also based on a book and that book a
Japanese book was called all you need is
kill which is just a way better name
than either the other names the Paper
Towns has been by most measures less
successful than The Fault in Our Stars
and that made me a little worried when I
was going to go see it because the thing
you don't want to have happen is you
know somebody makes some movie based on
you brothers book the big deals big
movie and then you go see it and you
don't like it that's the thing that you
really don't want to have happen I mean
it's not the end of the world if that
happens I just probably would be quiet
about it I'd be like Oh congratulations
on the movie John so imagine my relief
when the movie is good it's quite good I
like it a lot it's full of really great
moments I'm laughing out loud just like
clutching Katherine and the people
behind me in the theater having a great
time too the thing is it's a movie full
of normal people having normal but
wonderful moments and that's really kind
of what the movies about it's it's about
how life is full of these great moments
that happen to us but they aren't
necessarily exceptional in any way it's
not Frodo going to Mordor it's just
people having a good time having
adventures liking each other hanging out
having relationships coming to
understand each other more fully so in a
weird way the sort of success trajectory
of Paper Towns is very similar to this
sort of story of Paper Towns which is
that things don't have to be exceptional
for them to be good and for them to be
lovely experiences for the people who
make them and for the people who enjoy
that maybe
have a bigger impact on the people it
does impact even if it impacts a smaller
number of people because it really does
have a lot of practical knowledge of how
the world and relationships work maybe
that's part of why it isn't so
successful maybe that means that you
know how we measure success in general
isn't super great I know that it can be
stressful when stuff doesn't go exactly
as you want it to go but as your brother
and a fan of your work you want to say
John you're great and you make really
great stuff that people love and I'm
really proud of you so that's okay
moving we kind of got 10 topics real
fast so VidCon happened it was great I'm
really sort of buzzing with our
interesting online video and internet
culture is and what it means thank you
to everyone who made VidCon possible
from our sponsors to the attendees to
the creators to the whole team of people
that works on it so many wonderful
people and our volunteers and we just
had a great conference and I had a great
time and it was so freaked out
beforehand and I can't believe how well
it went so I'm just really happy a happy
I'm just even though I have to get a
colonoscopy tomorrow and I haven't been
able to eat anything today and I'm only
drinking Gatorade and that's my whole
calories for the day I'm really happy so
yeah this was my unscripted vlogbrothers
video unscripted and unfed and a little
bit unhappy because I got a have a
camera put in my butt tomorrow but other
than that things are going really great
John thank you for being a pretty cool
brother and I'll see you on Tuesday